president biden says he has no regrets
about the afghanistan collapse and his
botched strategy and our military
leaders say we have no capacity to
rescue americans in afghanistan i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news it is
horrific news this morning get to all of
it in just one second first quick
reminder you're paying too much for your
cell phone bill like you really are if
you're with verizon or at t or t-mobile
you're just paying too much it's time to
switch over to pure talk pure talk can
save your family over 800 a year you'll
get the same great coverage because pure
talk is on the exact same network as one
of the big three but at a fraction of
the price and switching is as easy as
switching out your sim card you can keep
your phone keep your number or get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids plus right now you can get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and if you go
over on the data they're not going to
charge you for it there's a reason pure
talk is considered the highest rated
wireless company by consumer affairs and
why they are the preferred wireless
partner of a mac so if you could save
money on your cell phone bill which is a
big bill every month why would you not
do that from your cell phone now pound
250 say ben shapiro save an additional
50 off your very first month of coverage
that's pounds 250 say ben shapiro to get
started with my friends over at pure
talk usa don't be paying for all the up
charges the big companies make you pay
instead use pure talk usa they'll pound
250 say ben shapiro save an additional
50 off your first month hundreds of
bucks down the road to get started to
pound two five zero seven shapiro to get
started alrighty so
the situation in afghanistan continues
to deteriorate there's now video of
clarissa ward from cnn trying to walk
the gauntlet from kabul just the main
area of the city into the airport and
the taliban stopping her threatening her
crew as she says it's nearly impossible
for any normal afghan to use their
papers to get out of the country at this
point meanwhile some 10 to 15 000
americans remain stranded in kabul at
this point according to eyewitnesses
this is sky news reporting desperate
women in kabul are attempting to throw
their babies over the razor wire to
american soldiers in scenes reminiscent
of saigon in which people are trying to
get the hell out of the country before
the taliban come in for all the people
out there who keep saying things like
well you know the people in afghanistan
they're just going back to what they
know remember the average age the
average age in afghanistan the median
age rather the median age is 18.4 years
old the united states has been occupying
afghanistan since 2001 20 years so the
average person in afghanistan actually
does not remember taliban rule the
average person in afghanistan has been
living in a country occupied by the
united states with a nascent democracy
for their entire lifetime and this is
particularly true for young women who
are now going to be subjected to sex
slavery and abuse and that is the next
move for young women all over the
country but particularly in the major
cities which were again a lot more urban
and a lot more controlled by the central
government than the rural outlying areas
according to sky news you can hear a
noise as you approach the high iron
gates that are the only way into the
compound that is the center of the
british airlift operation out of
afghanistan on either side of a narrow
road inside the walls of the compound at
kabul airport exhausted british soldiers
lie in the shade waiting for their turn
to head back outside into the burning
sun and the chaos once again the noise
is the sound of shouting it's the noise
of desperation thousands of people are
flooding toward this innocuous place
that will for some be the gateway to
freedom and for many others the end of a
dream of escaping the taliban after two
decades this is what it has come down to
a hasty retreat a civilian evacuation
with the taliban watching on as every
day passes this relief operation gets
more and more urgent and desperate as
the british military tries to move
thousands of people out of afghanistan
in just days it's a humanitarian mission
in what feels like a war zone
a makeshift barricade it's all that
separates the two armies who have fought
for 20 years the taliban are just one
meter away from the british soldiers a
picture i never thought i would see
writes stewart ramsey who's the chief
correspondent for the sky news
he says the
they're women who are
arriving day and night families often
with tiny children risking their lives
ducking past gunfire at the gates of the
civilian side of the airport passing
aggressive taliban fighters who
occasionally beat and harass them in the
night the paratroopers blockaded the
road with cars and razor wire a senior
officer told me they had no choice
because the situation was out of control
but said the black kid will live with
some of his soldiers for the rest of
their lives quote it was terrible women
were throwing their babies over the
razor wire asking the soldiers to take
them
some got caught in the wire i'm worried
for my men i'm counseling some everyone
cried last night
it looks like chaos but there's a method
the soldier called the soldiers call out
for interpreters as different
nationalities arrive at the barricade
including afghans with a valid asylum
case passports and paperwork are then
checked if they pass muster they're
direct is the entry gate to be processed
some make it others don't
terrified men
terrified families men women large
numbers of children are sent back
through the barbed wire
this is um unfortunately the reality in
afghanistan thanks to joe biden's
precipitous and meaningless and
meritless pull-out
fatima not her real name made it through
the barricade clutching her daughter's
hand she thinks she might have a case
but doesn't know who to speak to she's
terrified and in tears her husband
joined the taliban and took to beating
her she and her four-year-old have
nothing but a u.n letter identifying
them as victims afghanistan is taliban
taliban is terrorist my husband is a
terrorist talib she explains to me
she just says we'll go anywhere any
country
and this of course is going to be
common across afghanistan meanwhile
women across afghanistan of course are
being stuffed back into the burlap sacks
of the burka and uh and then back into
the basement according to the wall
street journal dr zuhl used to drive
herself to work this week she started
taking a taxi to avoid reprisals from
the taliban who wants banned women from
driving it didn't help on the second day
of the taliban take over a taliban
gunman dragged the doctor who didn't
want to use her full name out of the
taxi and whipped her for filming the
cast surrounding the evacuations at the
kabul airport
since he's in control of afghanistan the
taliban have sought to portray
themselves as more moderate than they
were last time now remember last time
the taliban took over in 1996 they also
pledged to be moderate and to amnesty
everybody who was fighting them and then
they proceeded to be one of the most
brutal regimes on planet earth
dr zuhal was six years old when the
taliban took over kabul the first time
in 1996 the same age as her daughter is
now i have so many dreams for her she
said my life and my achievements are
tearing in two pieces in front of my
eyes i never want this to happen to my
daughter already women are retreating
from the public sphere
fatima galana one of the few women that
negotiated with the taliban as part of
the afghan government declined to
comment fawzia koufi an outspoken
women's rights defender and
parliamentarian said she was unable to
give interviews under the current
circumstances in kabul many young women
have never even worn a burqa some often
appeared in public without headscarves
the wealthiest neighborhoods have come
to resemble the west with yummy young
afghan men and women mixing freely in
cafes modeled on starbucks
that's the lifestyle fatima hosseini a
28 year old photographer was accustomed
to now she's afraid of appearing in
public
i had my liberty i had my freedom we
went to the gym to restaurants sometimes
i would not cover my hair in public
everything has changed in a week
right this is the situation in
afghanistan the good news is that we
have president empathy out there the
most empathetic president of all time
right super grandpa empathy he's out
there just to show how much he cares
what an empathetic guy now quick
reminder
he's not empathetic he has never been
empathetic
back in 2010 he was asked by richard
holbrook then the special envoy by the
obama administration to afghanistan and
pakistan about a hasty withdrawal from
afghanistan and what that would mean for
the people of afghanistan and the people
who had allied themselves with us
sacrificed their lives sacrificed
themselves on behalf of yes an american
mission in afghanistan
and his explicit response according to
richard holbrook's diary this is joe
biden was quote f that nixon and
kissinger got away with it in vietnam
okay and uh and joe biden's main message
here is no regards
this is an astonishing clip so he was uh
he was interviewed by george
stephanopoulos and when a democratic
president is interviewed by george
stephanopoulos usually it is a human
centipede performance because that's
george stephanopoulos job george
stephanopoulos was the press secretary
for hillary clinton back during the
1990s he is a democrat democratic
apparatchik who somehow ended up as one
of the chief anchors at abc news which
is wild right imagine if karl rove were
one of the chief anchors for fox news
he'd be very strange
not like an opinion host the chief
actual news anchor so normally when
george stephanopoulos is um is
doing an interview with the democratic
politician it it looks more like soft
core pornography than it does like an
actual interview but george
stephanopoulos could not say biden from
himself here
he just could not
so he asks him a pretty simple question
he asked him it's chaos at the airport
right we're watching people fall from
planes joe biden's answer here is one of
the most atrocious answers i've ever
heard from an american president on any
topic and go back and listen i was
highly critical of many of the things
that trump said in interviews i was
certainly critical of the stuff that
obama said in interviews on a regular
basis
this is i think the worst thing i've
ever heard an american president say in
an interview and that encompasses a lot
of bad things being said in interviews
here is george stephanopoulos with the
presidents of the united states god help
us joe biden
we've seen those hundreds of people
packed into a c-17 we've seen
afghans fall
four days ago five days ago what did you
think when you first saw those pictures
well i thought was weird we have to gain
control of this we have to move this
more quickly
we have to move in a way in which we can
take control that airport
and we did
so you don't think this could have been
handled this actually could have been
handled
better in any way no mistakes
no
no no mistakes it's been error free it's
a perfect it's a perfect operation a
perfect operation where afghans are
clinging to the wheel wells of planes
escaping afghanistan and then falling
from 4 000 feet to their death on the
tarmac
perfect perfect operation more than that
i gotta say when stephanopoulos asks him
about
what just happened there he says it was
four or five days ago
so
number one i was unaware that if a man
falls 4 000 feet from the wheel well of
a c-17 to the tarmac that he remains
alive four or five days later that he
actually dies and then four or five days
pass and then he's okay again it was
four or five days ago that is the
response of this petulant man-child
president this adult
this adult president his response is it
was four or five days ago
what
what if it was a year ago would that
make it
four or five days ago
how in the world is that supposed to
make any difference at all by the way it
wasn't it was two days ago when he gave
this interview
i understand that every time joe biden
takes a mid-morning nap and wakes up he
thinks it's a new day but it absolutely
is not
okay this is this is just
an astonishing dear election by the
president of the united states and for
captain empathy over here to be saying
it was four or five days ago and could
you have handled anything better here no
nothing could have been handled better
nothing
truly nothing there are seven people who
are trampled to death at this airport
we have women throwing babies over the
razor wire at this airport we still have
10 to 15 000 americans american citizens
who are stuck in kabul
right now
as we speak
we have another somewhere between 60 and
100 000 afghan allies people who worked
with our military interpreters
members of the special operations forces
in afghanistan
for whom american soldiers have signed
affidavits by basically saying that
these are people who we ought to save
these aren't random syrian citizens who
are just being put upon by the
government and we don't have any
background information on them
these are people who actively worked
with the united states government with
our military with our military
contractors
they're stuck over there and joe biden
can't explain
how he could have done this any better
hey then joe biden goes even further
right he says well there was no way no
way that we could have gotten out
without chaos this was inevitable this
was the inevitable ending to this saga
inevitable
we were holding
our bases in afghanistan with a skeleton
crew of somewhere between 2 500 and 3
500 people
if you look at the number of troops
united states troops on the ground in
afghanistan year on year it had declined
essentially every year since 2014.
we went from having tens of thousands of
troops as in like 30 40 50 to 100 000
troops
in the in the 2010 2011-2012 period all
the way down to about 10 000 troops in
the post 2014 period and then all the
way down to 2 500 troops officially in
afghanistan as of january of this year
and joe biden decided that we had to
precipitously pull out so he could get a
headline about how he'd ended the
quote-unquote endless war
the thing that's so amazing about that
by the way is that when you look at
where american troops are stationed all
over the world
afghanistan barely ranks in like the top
by the time that we left
afghanistan had 25 3 500 troops there we
have over 5 000 troops in qatar we have
5 000 troops in kuwait
we have 26 000 troops in korea we have
something like 12 000 troops in italy
we have 40 000 troops still in japan we
have 33 000 troops in germany
this is not a quote-unquote endless war
for the united states there is no
necessity for this quote-unquote
precipitous pull-out and when he says
there's no way to get out without chaos
no there absolutely was
here is joe biden saying this it's
insane
the idea that somehow
there's a way to have gotten out without
chaos ensuing i don't know how that
happens
i don't know how that happened so for
you that was always priced into the
decision yes
unbelievable by the way quick note here
if you thought it was inevitable that
this chaos was going to happen
then why was he taking a vacation
really
why
by the way a bit of a conflicting
message there we were told by his
military was totally unexpected a month
ago he was saying that the taliban would
not be able to take hubble so either he
was lying then or he's lying now those
are the only two choices
or he's lying both times it is quite
possible that he was informed by his
intelligence community that this was a
significant possibility he lied about it
a month ago then it happened and then he
said oh yeah it was totally foreseeable
so he's lying both times that's the most
probable situation
i mean remember he says there was no way
to get us out without chaos just a month
ago here is joe biden saying this ain't
going to be saigon
do you see any parallels between this
withdrawal and what happened in vietnam
with some people feeling whatsoever zero
what you had is you had entire brigades
breaking through the gates of our
embassy
six if i'm not mistaken
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan it is not at all comfortable
that was july 8th
july 8th
unbelievable
un
freaking believable by the way joe biden
also told george stephanopoulos that uh
the taliban have changed said what i
think they're going through a sort of
existential crisis about what they want
to be do what they
about do they want to be recognized by
the international community as being a
legitimate government yeah that's that's
exactly right probably they're going
through an existential crisis
well done sir he's a delusion delusional
fully delusional
and by the way biden is now saying he is
grateful to the taliban he says i'm not
sure i would have predicted george nor
would you or anyone else than when we
decided to leave that they'd provide
safe passage for americans to get out
are we sure they've provided safe
passage for americans to get out at this
point
we'll get to that in just one second and
this is full-scale insanity first let us
talk about your sleep quality so i'll be
honest with you i haven't been sleeping
particularly well given the situation in
the world but when i do lay my head down
i need to be on a mattress that is
perfect for me a mattress made just for
me helix sleep is that mattress they've
made a quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else with
helix you're getting a mattress you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody is unique helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot even a helix plus mattress for plus
size folks so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your doorship for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix is awesome you don't
need to take my word for it helix is
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by both gq and
wired magazine just go to
take their two minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they've got a 10 year warranty
you have to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
ben right now that's
helixsleep.com for 200 bucks off your
magical mattress order helix sleep.com
ben by the way joe biden the only
interviews he's doing are with people
like george stephanopoulos
that the and the reason for that is
because he doesn't want to take tough
questions george stephanopoulos is there
to massage biden through these awkward
moments these awkward moments here was
joe joe biden gave a speech yesterday on
vaccination
public speech and vaccination and then
he just took off he ran from the room
because this is what the man does
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops thank you
[Music]
goodbye catch you later
see you later
and he's out
hey now he may be out but the americans
who are stuck in afghanistan absolutely
are not
according to walter russell mead writing
for the wall street journal some 15 000
u.s citizens and residents are behind
taliban lines there is no easy way to
get them out
by the way that is not even talking
about our afghan allies who worked with
us remember just about a month ago
biden's adviser cedric richmond was on
with jake tapper and he said pretty
openly we're not going to leave the
afghans behind we can't leave these
people behind
president biden publicly promised that
none
of the more than 19 000 afghans uh who
have assisted the united states and at
least begun the process of trying to get
these special immigrant visas to flee
afghanistan so they won't be slaughtered
by the taliban none of them he said will
be left behind when the military pulls
out in the coming weeks and months but
but the biden administration has been
very light on details nothing has
happened yet
these people respectfully sir need more
than words and and promises they need
action jake you know that this is a
serious issue i think that the president
was very clear that he's not leaving
people behind but if you're asking us to
give you numbers locations and details
and timing
we're not necessarily going to do that
because of the sensitivity of the
information we want to make sure that we
protect
the people who helped us and risked
their lives to help us
um no you know you're not protecting the
people who risked their lives and helped
us anyway as we're going to see the
entire military intelligence apparatus
is now saying a lot of those people are
gonna get left behind so they're just
damned liars according to walter russell
meet it's not just the afghans however
one thing is clear the taliban hold the
lives of thousands of u.s citizens and
futures and the future of the biden
administration in their hands the
collapse of the ghani government left as
many as 15 000 americans and permanent
residents along with an unknown number
of other westerners and foreigners
trapped behind taliban lines tens of
thousands of afghans employed by the old
government allied military commands and
western oriented non-profits are with
their family members also desperate to
leave while u.s forces control the kabul
airport american citizens and afghans
with u.s visas must run a gauntlet of
taliban roadblocks and checkpoints to
reach the american perimeter as for the
thousands of americans citizens of
allied nations and endangered afghan
national strands in other parts of the
country at press time u.s officials had
no plan in place to bring them to safety
congressional offices report being
deluged with pleas for help from
americans behind enemy lines and from
veterans seeking help for afghan contact
and friends i've told you about how i'm
receiving emails i right i'm just a
political commentator i'm receiving
emails from people asking how do i get
somebody out i'm getting calls from
people how do i get somebody out
okay this is utter craziness i got a
letter last night quote i'm a former
marine officer that serves in helmand
afghanistan in 2011. i've been trying to
assist my afghan interpreter tommy with
an siv for years now he served
tenaciously in fact i witnessed his
vehicle getting blown up in front of me
from an ied even after this episode he
continued to work with and put his faith
in us tommy is currently stranded with
his wife and young daughter a few miles
from the kabul airport together he and i
are devising evacuation plans but as you
know the situation on the ground is very
dangerous and uncertain and then this
marine officer asked for help in how do
we get this guy out okay that is the
situation on the ground and for american
citizens as well
while 1100 u.s citizens permanent
residents and family members were
evacuated on tuesday according to the
wall street journal there were reports
of people being beaten and turned back
from the airport
apparently the u.s government is
basically begging the taliban to let
people out
and the us government has made clear
that they can't actually provide people
passage according to caitlyn collins the
cnn chief white house correspondent the
u.s embassy in kabul told american
citizens in a security alert quote the
united states government cannot ensure
safe passage to the hamid karzai
international airport adding space on
evacuation flights will now be available
on a first come first serve basis
so the us government is saying we can't
even get you to the airport we can't
uber can get you to the airport we can't
get you to the airport
all these people in afghanistan all the
afghans are trying to erase their links
with the american government they're
trying to just erase the fact they ever
worked with the american government
because if the taliban find out that
they did they will be murdered
that is the situation on the ground the
taliban for their part this is the
funniest story of the day
grimly hilarious
so there are all these images coming out
of the taliban beating the living hell
out of people and shooting people
the taliban quote they deny their
fighters have been involved in this sort
of violence blaming the injuries on men
impersonating the taliban ah you know
those famous taliban impersonators it's
like elvis impersonators in vegas
taliban impersonators in kabul
there is no real taliban it's just in
your mind
maybe taliban is just an idea it's like
antifa it's just an idea out there in
just a second we'll get to the utter
inability of the west to provide safe
passage to american citizens to get out
and the fact that the likely
next step is going to be bribery your
taxpayer dollars are going to go
straight to the taliban that is the next
step here we all know it we'll get to
that in just one moment first
let us talk about the fact that right
now there are more open jobs than there
are people applying for those jobs right
now in the united states that can make
it difficult for employers it can also
make it difficult for employees to find
the right job well this is where zip
recruiter comes in according to forbes
gyms nail salons hotels mom and pop
stores and more are set to go on an epic
hiring spree in the coming months to
meet the pent-up demand for all of those
services all of those businesses
reopening means millions of jobs will
need to be filled and already need to be
filled so where do those businesses turn
to fill those roles fast zip recruiter
and right now you can try ziprecruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com dailywire
when you post a job on zip recruiter
they send your job to over 100 top job
sites giving you access to their network
of millions of job seekers ziprecruiters
matching technology scans resumes to
find qualified candidates for your open
roles and proactively presents them to
you you can easily review recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job which encourages
them to apply faster according to zip
recruiter internal data jobs where
employers invite candidates to apply get
two and a half times more candidates
zipper brutus technology is so effective
four out of five employers who post down
zip recruiter will get a quality
candidate within the very first day we
use zip recruiter here at dailywire you
should as well right now try ziprecruit
for free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y w-i-r-e zip recruiter.com
dailywire just go to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire zip recruiter is the smartest
way to hire alrighty so it's an absolute
disaster in afghanistan as far as
getting people out the nato secretary
general said yesterday well you know
nato is telling the taliban we expect
them to provide safe passage this is
jens stoltenberg the nato secretary
general well as long as you guys are are
telling them that you expect them to
provide safe passage i'm sure the
taliban will do what you say or
alternatively the taliban now holds all
the cards
because the united states decided to
withdraw with no plan at all to even
protect the american citizens on the
ground the taliban hold all the cards
what happens if the taliban just say no
is the united states going to deploy
thousands of troops into kabul to go
house to house to find the american
citizens were there is that do you think
joe biden's going to do that
i don't
what are you going to do
sanction the taliban they have no
economy
what exactly is the threat here you guys
just abandoned the place and then you're
like you better let out our guys why
would they do that the answer is they
would do that if we bribe them okay that
is the next step here the next step is
that the biden administration is going
to send pallets of cash to the taliban
and then biden is going to say look how
they moderated look at that they
moderated they let all of our people out
so really this isn't that bad i handled
this beautifully everybody got out and
then a few weeks later the taliban will
emerge from their caves to explain that
in fact they were given billions of
dollars by the biden administration
hundreds of millions of dollars by the
biden administration in order to free
what are essentially american hostages
now in afghanistan
and they they'll humiliate biden that is
how this is going to play out with like
75 certainty like anyway here's the nato
secretary general threatening with
nothing
our diplomats on the ground our people
on the ground are working
hard to
enable those who are threatened those
who have worked for us staff and others
to enable them to get to the airport and
also sending a very clear message to
taliban that we expect them to provide
safe passage
to enable people to
get to the airport as of now it seems
like what you're saying is this depends
on the good graces of the taliban
we don't control the territory outside
the uh airport
so yes that's yes this is we are relying
on the good graces of the taliban the
taliban have no good graces the only
reason that they release the americans
here is if they're paid off
that is the only reason because what
exactly is joe biden going to do launch
a bunch of airstrikes into the
countryside
what exactly is nato going to do at this
point reoccupy
they're not going to do any of that
stuff and the taliban know it
you just surrendered the country to a
bunch of 8th century barbarian
cavemen and now you're like maybe
they'll be nice maybe by the way again
joe biden is saying they will be nice he
is telling george stephanopoulos maybe
they'll moderate
cia analyst matt zeller who's been on
cnn a lot he said here's what the
taliban's actually doing they're taking
people's passports in kabul so if you
show up with a passport to try and get
past the barricade and get into the
airport they'll just take your passport
from you
we need to basically tell the taliban
that they need to shut down their
checkpoints in the city because they're
actively taking people's passports i've
had u.s citizens who have had their u.s
passports taken from them their green
cards taken from them afghans are having
their documentation stolen from them by
the taliban an attempt to prevent them
from being able to even get into the air
base
okay meanwhile the secretary of defense
of the united states at the the most
powerful military presence in the
history of the world
he says he's asked about evacuating
americans and he can't guarantee that we
will keep troops in there for for long
enough to even evacuate americans look
at the way he's hedging his bets here
this is because this is reality okay
when we say that we are going to
evacuate 10 to 15 000 americans they're
a bunch of americans who are out there
in the countryside they ain't coming
home
they're a bunch of americans in kabul
many of those people will not be coming
home
the biden administration knows this
because they blew it they blew it all
the way here is the defense secretary of
the united states of america talking
about how we cannot evacuate americans
thanks to a ragtag backwater group of
cavemen firing ak-47s
and who were just handed billions of
dollars in american military technology
by a surrendering american pusillanimous
president
this is this is so humiliating it's the
most humiliating thing i've ever seen in
my life with regard to american foreign
policy i mean it is not close
i think it may be the most humiliating
thing any american has ever seen in
their lifetime period and it took two
years for the united states to after the
united states large scale withdrawal
from vietnam it's about two years for
everything to collapse in vietnam this
took about five minutes and now the
united states is left begging and
pleading with the taliban to evacuate
american citizens here's the defense
secretary of the most powerful military
power in the history of the world
saying
that you know we'll try and get people
out until the clock runs out by the way
when he says until the clock runs out
that is a tacit admission that we are
now working on the taliban's timetable
we're really working hard uh to get as
many people through
uh as possible and quite frankly we're
not we're
it's obvious we're not close to where we
want to be in terms of getting the
numbers through so we're going to work
that 24 hours a day seven days a week
and we're going to get everyone
that we can possibly
evacuate
it and i'll do that as long as we
possibly can until the clock runs out or
we run out of capability
okay we'll do it until the clock runs
out or we run out of capability the are
you talking about
the clock runs out who's clock
who's clock there are only two players
in the scenario the taliban and biden
that's it
no other players so whose clock are we
talking about joe biden's artificial
timeline for getting out or are we now
talking about the fact that the taliban
has set a clock for the united states to
leave and joe biden is going to obey the
clock
of again the worst people on planet
earth
these barbarians that's who we're going
to obey that's the or our military
capability runs out our military
capability we spend
billions hundreds of billions of dollars
every year on the united states military
our capability runs out for doing what
driving people to the airport in
defiance of a rag-tag group of people
armed with like bicycle locks
like what what are you what the what are
you talking about what that's the
secretary of defense of the united that
guy needs
that guy needs to be out he needs to he
needs to resign that frankly biden
should resign i mean he's not going to
obviously he's not going to be impeached
by a democratic congress but if anybody
had any stones they would
this is the most pathetic thing i've
ever seen in my life as an american
citizen
it is the most muelling pathetic
disreputable thing i've ever seen in my
life in terms of american foreign policy
and it is not close we saw a lot of crap
under barack obama
this is
abjectly pathetic the state department
press secretary wendy sherman was asked
about this yesterday and she says well
no government could evacuate all these
citizens no one could really i mean when
you think about it it's really hard well
yeah it is hard when you get rid of all
the american troops that are protecting
all the air bases that allowed people to
leave yes that does make it rather
difficult does it not maybe somebody
should have conveyed that to the
president or maybe having conveyed that
to the president if he insisted on going
ahead with his plan somebody should have
resigned in protest didn't we hear that
a lot during the trump administration if
you hate it so much you should leave
well
well anyone bueller here's wendy sherman
kabul i don't know if you've ever been
there is an enormous city
enormous
and it has um
uh
in fact had more and more people come to
kabul because they thought it was the
safest place to be in afghanistan
so it is
difficult under any circumstances and i
don't know of any
uh government that would be capable of
reaching out to where everybody might be
particularly those who have not signed
up to us to help them
which is why you shouldn't have
surrendered the city
lloyd austin doubled down on this the
secretary of defense says we don't have
the capacity to collect our people we
just don't we can't do it right so
originally what was funny about this
particular exchange is that mark milley
we'll get to in just one second the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
who's so concerned about white rage
white rage
it's really it's really fortunate we
have such geniuses running our military
establishment nobody gets fired for
losing wars around here it's pretty
impressive
what am i you want to talk about a
government make work program apparently
the joint chiefs of staff is one of them
so is the defense secretary ship
so so he started off this little
exchange mark mainly by saying this is a
political problem and then lloyd austin
jumps in to save the president
he says no it's not it's not a political
problem it's a capacity problem
i would draw a distinction bar between
extracting
someone in an in extremist condition or
or circumstance versus uh going out and
collecting up large numbers of uh of
american citizens you have the
capability to go out and collect
americans
we don't have the capability to go out
and collect up large
numbers of
of people
we don't have the capability to collect
them okay you know what that capability
amounts to it amounts to literally you
drive a car where the citizen is you
pick them up in your car you bring them
back to the airport he's saying we can't
do that the reason they can't do that is
because the taliban have set up
checkpoints
and so what they're really afraid of is
that somebody will get into a shooting
fight with the taliban at the outskirts
of the airport and then the airport will
be overrun by the taliban that is the
fear the fear is that america will
attempt to deploy its forces into kabul
in order to pick up all the americans
and the taliban won't let them and then
you'll be in a shooting war and bride
doesn't want that because he doesn't
want to have to put troops back into
kabul and then have an urban fight with
the taliban in a city that he just
conceded so instead we'll just leave the
americans out there and then we'll hope
that the taliban are nice and the
taliban will be nice so long as we pay
them american taxpayer dollars so they
can continue to
propagate their
evil regime
of rape torture and tyranny
that's all that's happening here the
united states is now going to be the
chief funder of the taliban
that's what's going to happen we are
going to end up giving them the money
because how else are we going to get our
guys out and why exactly would they let
us get our guys out if that's the case
meanwhile joe biden had to be bullied by
george stephanopoulos into making a
commitment to leave american troops
there as long as necessary to get the
americans out by the way that's not
going to happen they're going to be
americans who get stuck in afghanistan
i'm just saying that's going to happen
right now and if it doesn't happen it's
because joe biden's going to bribe the
taliban
the commitment holds to get everyone out
that in fact we can get out and everyone
should come out and that's the objective
that's what we're doing now that's the
path we're on and i think we'll get so
americans should understand that troops
might have to be there beyond august
31st no americans should understand that
we're going to try to get it done before
august 31. but if we don't
the troops will if they don't we'll
determine at the time who's left
and
and if they're american forces if
there's american citizens left we're
going to get them all out
oh my god
you see it's unbelievable george
stephanopoulos has to walk him through
that right so he gives an answer and his
answer is basically we'll determine at
the end of the august 31st deadline
who's left
and stephanopous is like um what now
so you're saying that if they're america
if there are americans left we might
leave anyway
so he has to prompt biden until he gets
to the right answer there and
and
usually massage his ass until the
correct answer comes popping out of
there so george george stephanopoulos is
doing here
amazing stuff
okay but don't worry it's not just joe
biden who ought to resign and lloyd
austin our pathetic defense secretary
who ought to resign uh it's it's
american it's the entire infrastructure
the entire infrastructure ought to be
thrown out on their butts they all ought
to be thrown out on their butts we'll
get to mark milly
the the
important investigator of military white
rage in just one second first let's talk
about your mortgage so your mortgage is
certainly the biggest bill you have
every single month there's no reason for
it to be you could get it refined right
and if you haven't refined it you're
making a mistake since the pandemic
started 20 of homeowners have refined
their homes that is a very smart
decision because you likely save
yourself hundreds of dollars a month am
i right now what about the rest of you
are you waiting for rates to drop
further are you happy with what you have
no matter your answer it doesn't hurt to
get a free mortgage review from american
financing there's no obligation no
upfront or hidden fees they're just
going to take a look at what you're
paying maybe review some of your other
debts then they will discuss custom loan
options that can save you up to a
thousand bucks a month and it only takes
a 10 minute call to get started
if you like what you hear they'll get
you pre-qualified for free so what are
you waiting for call
866-721-3300 that's
866-721-3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls 182 334 nmls consumeraccess.org go
check them out right now
americanfinancing.net 866 721 3300
that's 866 721 3300 or check out
americanfinancing.net to go check out
your possibilities on a mortgage refi
all right we'll get to more in just one
second on this again horrific day in
american history
the most pathetic display frankly i have
ever seen in my life from the united
states first if you haven't yet pulled
the trigger and joined the daily wear
i'm going to assume you haven't heard of
our reader's past that's a steal for
just four bucks a month the daily wire
readers pass unlocks exclusive editorial
content that unpacks trending political
and cultural topics penned by everybody
from me to dan crenshaw plus analysis
pieces like my brand new analysis piece
4 000 words long here's what went wrong
in afghanistan and here's what we should
have done differently or take a deep
dive with readers past collections
different series of articles on a given
subject current collections include a
culture in crisis and blm the
organization behind a movement when you
sign up with readers pass you also get
access to the morning wire newsletter a
monday through saturday email covering
the top stories you need to know
available only to daily wire members all
of this can be yours for just four
dollars a month so act fast because
right now we're offering a one month
free trial it is a good deal it's also
never been a better time to take it so
what are you waiting for get informed
get a reader's pass today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so the rest of our military
infrastructure just as bad as lloyd
austin you'll remember general mark
milley the joint chiefs of staff chair
the heroic joint chiefs of staff chair
who stood up to the predations of donald
trump he said that donald trump had a
reichstag fire moment made no sense
about the january 6th events he also was
preoccupied preoccupied with the problem
of whiterage went in front of congress
and explained why he had assigned troops
to read ibramax kennedy's garbage it was
very important
our focus in the military is on all the
things that matter
like six weeks ago mark milley was was
talking about how important it was to
study white rage or was mark milley just
six weeks ago
i'm not gonna
address specifically white rage or black
rage or asian rage or irish for age or
english phrase or german or any other
age right but i do think it's important
that we as a professional military
not only understand foreign countries
and foreign cultures and foreign
societies that's important that we do
that
but we also need to understand our own
society and and understand the soldiers
sale as airman marines uh and the
society they're coming from and i think
that's important for leadership to study
thank you you said the words white rage
yeah i said i'm not going to discuss it
right now i think it's a very
complicated topic and we don't have the
time to go into the nuance of it right
this minute
it's so nuanced so important we had to
study it and we had to spend time on it
and when we weren't spending time with
our military leaders when we weren't
spending time with white rage our
pentagon was spending time attacking
tucker carlson for making disparaging
comments about uniforms for pregnant
pilots
right here is our military back in march
this is march 11 2021. john kirby the
pentagon spokesperson saying i want to
be very clear right up front the
diversity of our military is one of our
greatest strengths uh would be winning
would winning wars
be one of our greatest strengths in the
military would abandoning our posts be
one of the greatest strengths of the
military because i'm hearing that that
uniforms for pregnant pilots are very
very important to the pentagon um but
not getting our asses kicked by a bunch
of backwater tribesmen is apparently not
super important to our pentagon when
i've seen it for myself in long months
at sea and in the combat wage by our
troops in iraq and afghanistan i've seen
it up on capitol hill just this past
month i see it every day right here at
the pentagon said john kirby what we
absolutely won't do is take personal
advice from a talk show host or the
chinese military maybe those folks feel
like they have something to prove that's
on them well i feel like the us military
leadership not the military men and
women the military leadership has
something to prove like can you win a
god bleeping war how about that
i feel like you have something to prove
can you win a war can you not surrender
to can you not leave 10 to 15 000
americans hanging out in kabul waiting
for the taliban to arrive at their homes
with the bull whips
maybe you have something to prove or but
i understand look it's a busy time in
the u.s military infrastructure right in
the higher chain of the us military it
is a busy time you have to make sure
that you're pushing diversity
transgender troops and white rage all
those things those are things that the
defense department has to be on top of
day in and day out what they don't
really have to be on top of is whether
afghanistan is going to collapse inside
of two weeks if the united states
military pulls out and abandons our
afghan allies in fact that's what we
were told by general mark milley
literally yesterday mark milley came out
he said i had no information that would
have led to this
really yet no one there were no
indicators none seriously like none
this was a talking point for people who
followed foreign policy for literally
years that if the united states pulled
out the taliban would take over within
weeks
this is no shock to anybody who's
watching this thing with any level of
knowledge but mark listen when you're
reading ibrahmax candy i understand it's
absorbing stuff you can't be bothered to
actually worry about what's going to
happen in afghanistan now mark milley
apparently was giving warnings according
to the washington post to biden that
this was a bad idea
but apparently that didn't require any
contingency planning by mark miller or
anything i mean the man does have
priorities here he was yesterday
the time frame of a rapid
collapse that was widely estimated and
ranged from weeks to months and even
years
following our departure
there was nothing
that i or anyone else saw
that indicated a collapse
of this army and this government in 11
days
nothing he saw by the way nothing well i
mean to be fair he wasn't seeing a lot
of stuff
it is very busy being woke very busy he
didn't see anything here's nbc news
yesterday reporting that the cia warned
of a rapid collapse like weeks ago
nbc news has learned that in recent
weeks the cia had been warning about a
potentially rapid takeover by the
taliban and total collapse of the afghan
military and government but we don't
know if that message ever got to the
white house right
yeah that's right joe and really the
washington blame game is in full swing
at this point you have military
officials saying they wanted to begin
evacuating our afghan partners as early
as may but they were prevented from
doing so by the white house you have the
intelligence community saying they were
shocked at the speed at which the
military completed that drawdown within
afghanistan that was mostly done by july
oh well but i was informed by mark
milley that uh there was no way anybody
could have foreseen this
at the same time i was being told by
president biden that everyone forced a
lot so really strange the conflicting
messages coming out of this garbage
administration really strange by the way
you know it's not just joe biden we've
been hearing that it's the biden harris
administration see that's the way that
the press likes to work this thing it's
the biden-harris administration when
they're doing something the press loves
but as soon as it's
a bad thing that everybody acknowledges
is bad
then it just becomes the biden
administration there's only one problem
for kamala harris the successor to joe
biden who's on his last legs here she
owns this she was part of this according
to noah biermann writing for the los
angeles times vice president kamala
harris has been at least visually front
and center as president biden has
overseen america's retreat from
afghanistan she attends most of his
security briefings and had to leave a
meeting with business leaders thursday
afternoon to attend an urgent
intelligence session as the taliban
rapidly cemented control over the
country
when the white house released a photo
sunday of biden sitting alone at a
telebriefing from the situation room in
camp david harris was on the other end
of the screen occupying the central
square among biden's coterie of virtual
advisors she watched his high profile
speech monday from a nearby room at the
white house a detailed officials made
sure to highlight in a continuing effort
to brand the biden harris administration
as an unusually close team
the harrowing images are likely to be a
defining moment in biden's presidency
but the execution of the withdrawal will
also be added to harris's resume
yup they own this crap they own it they
own it all the way there is no unowning
it or disowning it not going to happen
nancy pelosi for her part she can
enthusiastically embrace any
piece of
horrifying news coming out of her own
party a woman who enthusiastically
embraces the rashida talib ilhan omars
and aocs on the cover of rolling stone
can certainly embrace a complete rapid
pull out from afghanistan that results
in the complete subjugation of 38
million human beings and the essential
hostage taking of 10 to 15 000 americans
inc i mean what can't nancy pelosi
embrace what can not nancy pelosi
embrace if called upon to do so by her
god the democratic party here is nancy
pelosi defending joe biden
i commend the president for the action
that he took it was strong it was
decisive and it was the right thing to
do
we should have been out of afghanistan a
while back
but now we are
unfortunately
one of the possibilities was that it
would be
a dis
in disarray as it is but that has to be
corrected and it is my understanding
from the assurances we have received
that the
military will be there negotiating with
the taliban for the safe exit of
american citizens and friends people who
have helped us our allies there
oh we're going to be negotiating that's
going to work yeah that it'll be
bribery gang watch for the pallets of
cash i'm telling you right now bribery
if you like paying your tax dollars to
the taliban you can thank joe biden for
that because that's exactly what we are
going to be doing
you think that it was a big mistake to
spend you know 40 billion or so propping
up the the afghan government and making
sure that we had a base of operations
from which to strike terrorists in in
afghanistan wait until we're paying
billions of dollars to the taliban for
the tender grace of having them allow
american citizens to leave the country
meanwhile represent the democratic
defense of this is just it's amazing
they'll defend pretty much anything not
all of them right we played
representative seth moulton yesterday
ripping into biden but the most ardent
democrats absolutely will here's
representative barbara lee she says you
know it was just a matter of
unpreparedness i mean if we'd been a
little more prepared it would have been
fine
[Music]
i believe that uh the execution as all
of us have seen uh has not gone well i
believe that we should have been better
prepared but i also know that for
instance with many of the afghans who
have provided the type of assistance
that we desperately needed there were
very few lists of any of who they were
and so that's just an example of the
lack of preparedness
oh just unpreparedness guys perhaps the
best comment comes courtesy of
democratic representative jared golden
he was asked specifically about the fall
of the united states embassy here was
his response
the thought that the american embassy
there is going to be occupied by the
taliban on 9 11
2021 the 20th anniversary what emotions
go through your mind when you hear that
um it's a building
you know it's a building
um
i i let's let's point out by the way
we've still got about 6 000 troops on
the ground at kabul international
airport and uh hoping every one of them
comes home safe but their mission is
important they got to stay there until
we get all american personnel out safely
uh that's their job and i know that
they're proud to be doing it right now
man i mean golden should know better
than this he was a he was a marine he
was deployed to iraq and afghanistan his
congressman from from maine saying it's
a 700 million building that was
sovereign united states territory by the
way alrighty we'll be back here later
today with an additional hour of i'm
sure depressing content coming up soon
is the matt wall show airing at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show